اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم بايدن يقول ان بلاده
تعمل من اجل احلال السلام بين
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين بناء على حل
الدولتين نتنياهو يقول انه يسعى للتوصل
الى اتفاق مع حماس لكن ليس باي ثمن
ومسؤولون يون يتهمونه بالسعي لافشال
الصفقه من جانبه يقول كيربي ان واشنطن
تسعى لهدني ومسؤولون يتحدثون عن ضغط
امريكي نحو اتفاق هدنه طويل الاد يوقف
الزخم العسكري الاسرائيلي تجدون المزيد من
اخبار الحرب على غزه في رابط
بالتعليقات خلال اجتماعهم في العاصمه
البلجيكيه بروكسل قاده دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي يتفقون على اقرار مساعدات اضافيه
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 50 مليار يورو لاربع
سنوات ضمن خطه تمويل ثابت وطويل المدى
والرئيس الاوكراني يرحب بالاتفاق ويقول
انه سيعزز الاستقرار الاقتصاديه والماليه
لبلاده معترفا بتاثير منصاته على اطفالهم
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه ميتا مارك زكبير
يعتذر للعائلات في جلسه استماع بمجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي عن تاثير وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي على الاطفال بعد ان قامت اللجنه
بتشغيل مقطع فيديو يتحدث فيه الاطفال عن
تعرضهم للتنمر على منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي هيومان رايتس وتش تتهم عددا من
شركات صناعه السيارات العالميه بالتقاعس
عن تقليل مخاطر استخدام العمل القسري
للاجور في سلاسل توريد الالومنيوم لديها
تقرير المنظمه يفيد باستسلام بعض شركات
الصناعه السيارات من بينها جنرال موتورز
وتويوتا وتيسلا لضغوط الحكومه الصينيه
الهادف الى تبني معايير اضعف لحقوق
الانسان مقارنه بباقي عملياتها عالميا الى
اللقاء